hello everyone and welcome back to the
official random World Championship we
have an absolute Thriller of a game
between two world champions uh World
rapid Champion another back of the
satrov and World Fisher random Champion
Wesley so uh this is the second game of
their match and first the game ended in
uh in a brutal draw uh Wesley had the he
already had a winning position on like
move 19 but he missed the win then
another way got back into the game and
then throughout the entire game it
lasted like 80 moves uh Wesley was
winning on on a few uh other uh uh
occasions but uh he was unable to take
the full point in the end uh the game
ended by a repetition of moves with uh
Abdul Satur of having I think uh or no
Wesley having a night in Bishop for for
a rook with Queen still on the board it
was a really crazy positions uh there
was no way to get out of check so Wesley
was very sad that he couldn't grab the
full point with the white pieces and now
he has the black pieces against other
mix so let's see how this game went as
it's also a pretty pretty wild one so
let's dive straight into it if you guys
are interested this is the photo before
the actual game you can see that video
president arcaded workovic making the
first move uh both of them very happy
yeah you can see another can't wait for
the for the game to start just staring
at Wesley you can see it very rarely
will you see the eye contact so here at
least you have an attempt at eye contact
by another by khadoos maybe something
the new generation is bringing um to the
Chess World but uh we'll see how it goes
and you can see that uh arcade work
which made the first move Pawn to G3
which is the move that notary back
actually played so probably he asked him
uh before uh what movie if he wants to
play or maybe he just guessed it who
knows
does go for Pawn to G3 we have Pawn to
G6 by Wesley and now Knight to F3
already clearing the king side for for
white to the castle we have Pawn to C5
and already another big just Castle's
King side we have Knights the C6 uh Pawn
to C3 and now Pawn to D5 with Pawn to D4
and captures captures and here we have
this position where uh nothing is really
happening but white has uh some uh very
uh unpleasant pressure against Black's
position Wesley skin still in the center
of the board you can always capture an
E4 but you never really want to do it
you you kind of want to start developing
do you go best of stage three do you
attack The Rook do you go Knight to F6
so there are many possibilities here
Wesley goes for Bishop to G4 if he plays
Bishop to H3 The Rook is going to E1
regardless of that Bishop so uh he says
better to put the bishop here to prevent
to prevent the advancement of the e-pawn
so okay Rook fte1 the defends the E2
pawn queen to C8 now brings the queen
into the game and now Bishop to E3 now
with some ideas of maybe even capturing
and C6 and picking up the A7 Pawn so
Wesley just trades on D4 we have
captures uh Pawn captures on D4 and now
Bishop to G7
uh we have Rook to C1 now claiming the C
file for the Rooks uh Queen to E6 by
Wesley and now Rook the C7 a very nice
rock cliff going after the B7 Pawn so
Queen to B6 Wesley defends it and now uh
you would expect something like Rook e
to C1 doubling up on the C file and it
is in fact the the engine stop
recommendation the problem is uh are you
sure about giving up the E2 pawn and if
you're not sure maybe you just don't do
this so here yeah that's that's the
beauty of Chess 960 you just don't
sacrifice the pawn on move 11 on a hunch
even though you know it's it's probably
good but okay Rook to C5 by another back
um just getting the Rook out of Harm's
Way we have Knight to F6 and now Knight
the C3 uh we have Castle so Wesley also
castles his King to safety and pawn to a
for now preparing Pawn to a5b4 and so on
so here we have Bishop back to E6 also
uh adding more defense to that the D5
Pawn is it's attacked by the rugged by
the knight uh by the bishop on
H1 and now Pawn to A5 kicking away the
queen queen to A6 and pawn to B4 so now
you know that B5 is coming and then well
if B5 comes with the queen D6 Bishop F4
you might soon run out of squares for
your queen so here Rook the C8 clearing
that dates were for the black queen if
if B5 comes uh and then now we have
Bishop to F4 uh by another back also
very interesting is Queen to A4 but it's
merely a matter of how you want to trade
queens now let's say B6 captures
captures on A4 uh and after Knight
captures spawn captures on B6 now Rook
Knight will be captured on B6 attacking
The Rook here and after Rook to B8 you
can play something like Rook to C6 and
white keeps a very very
uh some unpleasant pressure here on the
queen side The Rook can come to B1 you
will already have a rook behind the pass
B Pawn so you can start advancing it
very unpleasant for Wesley but okay uh
this is a rapid chest and also it's fish
random so Bishop to F4 we have B6 now
eight captures on V6 Queen captures on
A1 and now we have a queen trade
captures captures The Rook is now
attacked uh we have Rook captures on C8
Rook captures in the Knight to B5 now uh
we have Bishop to D7 attacking the
Knight here and the Knight the C7 now we
have Pawn to E6 defending the pawn on D5
and Knight the A8 going after the B6
Pawn we have Knight to H5 now saying
okay if you capture on B6 you go after
the Rook I'm just gonna capture on D4
and go after your rook and A1 so you
have to defend the D4 Iron by playing
Bishop D5 or by playing Bishop to E3
another Beck prefers to keep the Bishops
on the board he goes Bishop to E3 and
now uh is the moment where we where the
magic happens and it's uh it's it's a
really wonderful position a really
complicated one and it will show you how
strong these guys really are so here
Wesley played Rook the B8 the pawn is
saying you have to defend the pawn he
plays Rook the B8 which turns out not to
be the greatest of most uh the way to
actually defend the pawn is by not
defending it you have to give it up in
order to pick up the B4 Pawn that's how
he played Bishop C6 let's say it goes
after the night and then after Knight
picks up the pawn now you play Rook the
B8 attack the Knight and the pawn and
after the Knight moves Knight C4 because
if Pawn captures then Bishop captures on
C6 now you just win back your Pawn Rook
captures on B4 and okay Knight gets the
fancy five square but let's say Bishop
captures D captures F6 you free up the
F7 Square for your king captures
captures and you get this position where
okay another back has the bishop pair
but it's equal material nothing
spectacular happening here however after
Wesley's move Rook to B8 it becomes much
much different here we have Pawn to G4
uh pushing the Knight away from the
control over the F4 Square Knight to the
F6 and Bishop to F4 now attacking that
Rook Rook the B7 you have to keep
defending the pawn on B6 and now comes
Knight to C7
freeing up the back rank for the uh for
the white rook and now how do you play
this uh we have Ponta H5 by Wesley upon
the H6 is a bit more precise Pawn the H5
allows another back a spectacular
spectacular idea that was not played in
the game but I will use it as a pause
the video moment because you guys really
want to solve this one you will feel
great for the entire day if not the
entire week uh so have at it feel free
to pause the video and win the game for
white while I give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it uh congratulations on uh spotting
that uh all of Wesley's pieces are
completely paralyzed and what I mean by
this is that they really are but it's
very hard to see why point is that here
uh another we play G captures an H5
which is not what you want to do here
you want to play G5 uh push the Knight
back or or forward doesn't really matter
if Knight's the E4 you're just gonna
capture it at some point but first Rook
to A8 with check and after the king
moves now you eliminate this Knight
which is basically Black's only active
piece characters captures and now a very
important move Bishop to D6 and why it's
important because uh you you really want
to play B5 and trap the bishop on D7 so
you can trap it it would Rook to d8 but
you don't want to allow black this ring
E5 move this uh forces you to react as
it comes with Tempo then the bishop gets
this diagonal so what you want to play
is Bishop the uh after this uh instead
of B5 Bishop to D6 and now there really
is no good way to play this even if you
give up the D4 Pawn you can allow Bishop
captures on D4 now just uh upon the B5
and the bishop has no squares Rook d8
will just trap the bishop whatever you
do Bishop G7 Rook to d8 and the bishop
is trapped you could try maybe some
other other tricky ideas if uh after
this um uh D captures an E4 move and
Bishop to D6 you try the immediate E5
okay you can free up your light Square
Bishop but then you have to allow D
captors on E5 and now look at this now
your dark Square Bishop is completely
trapped the the rook and Bishop covered
the f8 square pawns cover F6 and H6 The
Rook uh cannot move a single Square the
bishop can only roam this diagonal I
mean that's no way to to live let alone
play chess uh so uh that was possible
when Wesley pushed H5 but that's the
beauty of official random you just don't
expect such a thing to be possible and
also it's move 27 they still need to
make three more moves to reach time
control yeah so no little bit played G
characters on H5 he played it pretty
much with the same idea only without
actually blocking the position here and
trading the bishop for Knight so here
are Knight captures on H5 by Wesley
Bishop to D6 and now Bishop capture Sun
D4 he does go for Rook to A8 with Chuck
King to G7 and now Knight captures and
D5 very nicely done because if the
Knight is captured then Bishop captures
on D5 ended the Rook now has no squares
you have to give it up so after Knight
captures on D5 we have Bishop to C6 and
now Bishop to f8 with check King H7 and
now Knight to F6 check giving up this
Knight for the bishop and C6 so uh
Bishop captures on F6 Bishop captures
and C6 with Rook the C7 but now Pawn to
B5 again not allowing this Rook to move
it recovers A7 Bishop covers B7 and D7
the other Bishop cover z7 so The Rook
has no squares really
so Bishop D7 you have to activate it
somehow so you offer a trade of Bishops
and now you are able to sort of activate
it but this also allows another back a
very very simple winning position Bishop
captures Rook captures and now just Pawn
to E3 and uh uh again there's no good
way of activating The Rook so Knights to
F6 we have Rook to B8 going after the B
Pawn Knight the D5 this is one last
attempt at defending the position by
Wesleyan it's a nice one if not Rebecca
gets greedy and he goes Pawn to E4 to
kind of Chase away the defender of the
B6 Pawn then after let's say Knight
before Rook captures and Rook to A7 you
will still have some counter play and
it's not going to be all that simple
pushing that B Pawn to Victory but
instead we just trades Bishop for Knight
E Captain D5 and The Rook captures on V6
it goes into this rook and pawn and game
where he is up a past B Pawn and the
only way for Wesley to defend this is to
play Rook to E 5 but Wesley played Pawn
to D4 and now the position is completely
winning for another back but you have to
you have to realize why he captures on
D4 was played Rook to D7 and preparing
to recollect the pawn
and now only one winning idea for for
another back and I'm pretty sure you
guys um uh see it you have to start
advancing your B Pawn one way you don't
want to do it is by putting the Rook on
B8 this is uh having the rook in front
of your past Pawn when in fact you want
to have the Rook behind your pass Pawn
now let's say Rook captures on D4 B6
Rook to B4 now your opponent has has his
Rook behind the pass Pawn B7 King G7 and
you are and never getting this Rook off
of the B8 Square as the B7 Pawn will
hang so the way to do it is to play Rook
to F6 beautifully played as it comes
with Tempo knife row captures on D4
First You're Gonna grab this Pawn with
check and now you are you you go back
Rook to B7 but now you're up two pawns
so that's completely different so
instead after Rook F6 King the G7 Wesley
has to defend now Rook F3 now Shifting
The Rook to B3 and putting the Rook
behind the pass Pawn so Rook captures on
D4 Rook to B3 Rook to D7 and now Pawn to
B6 we have rooked the B7 Wesley a
blockades the position and now King to
G2 we have King to F6 and we have King
to G3 King to F5 uh sorry King to G3
um
uh King to F5 Point F4 by Wesley King to
F6 uh and now King to G4 we have King to
G7 King to G5 F6 with check and King to
G4 we have F5 with check another back is
basically waiting for that wasted to
deplete all of his uh useful pawn moves
so we have King to F3 King to F6 King to
E3 with King to E6 and now King to D4
and uh let me just check something real
quickly uh not really sure at which
point um
uh okay yeah that that makes sense
definitely uh so here uh in in this
position King the D6 was played and now
uh another back played Ponte H4 and he
was in this position on move 55 uh that
Wesley so resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here the problem
is now uh this is uh this is a two swung
if if you've ever seen one Whatever
black plays completely deteriorates his
possession if you push the pawn another
big just wins it if you move the king
you allow uh the white king to
infiltrate for example King C5 then King
D7 you can just play Rook check and then
the king moves you can just win some
squares here Rook here King here and
then you advance the pawn to Victory uh
if the King goes the other way it
doesn't really matter then you if the
King goes here you just go here you
collect the pawns uh you don't really
care about this Pawn anymore because you
are winning these pawns and if you don't
do either of the king moves if you just
move the Rogue then just B7 and again
yeah black really achieve nothing again
you will have to make a king move and
once you make a king move doesn't really
matter which one then we can again start
advancing our King King E5 you go after
the pawns and that's it so Elementary
end game and of course that's why Wesley
resigned after another pushed H4 there
is uh nothing more to be done here so uh
very very uh tough defeat for for Wesley
so who had a win in game one with the
white pieces uh like I said already uh
before move 20 and then throughout a few
times throughout the game but it was so
incredibly complicated he was unable to
grab the full point another big defended
well and then in the second game another
big just went into into an end game he
outplayed Wesley and it basically all
came down to this uh move where Wesley
decided the uh to defend the
uh sorry uh not here but uh
sorry about that uh where is the
position
yeah no this is already lost uh
yeah where is that position where that
weird one
uh
okay I'm I'm kind of losing my mind here
it's way way before that this is really
weird sorry about that
no this is already the real camera what
am I am I am I going mad what is this
the G5 okay we know that the G5 ah yeah
okay here I mean still me sorry about
that yeah I thought it was it was after
the the the the G4 G5 idea but yeah here
uh basically it all came down to this
where Wesley just should have given up
the the B6 Pawn went after the B4 Pawn
but instead he defended his pawn and I
believe that's what allowed this uh this
to just happen even by another missing
that uh brilliant brilliant idea by by
trapping uh the the lights for Bishop it
was still too too hard to defend
uh but yeah uh that's the game I hope
you guys enjoyed it and I said that we
were going to discuss the standings uh
after we show at least one more game so
these are the standings you have the two
groups another back now leading his
group and uh Magnus and Hikaru uh
Vladimir fedosa and matthiasm in the
other group and Hikaru is leading his
group with four points and okay Hikaru
and Magnus kind of are the favorites and
you expected them to advance from their
group but in this group where now you
have another
son it's not as clear as what will
happen because now another Beck is the
leader with three and a half points and
you have Yani pomonishi and the world
champion uh in in Fisher random Wesley
so on two points so not all three of
them will advance two two of them have
to drop out so it will be very
interesting to see what happens but okay
two two more days of uh group
preliminaries uh will be very
interesting to see what happens uh so
yeah that's the game and the standings
hope you guys enjoyed that sorry about
me going a bit crazy here at the end I
really thought it was after G5 but yeah
what do you want to do I mean it's
Fisher random weird positions
um you know you don't expect certain
positions to be hard to find but yeah
once again really hope you guys enjoyed
it the beautiful plate by neuterbeck uh
we'll we'll we'll see what happens on
the in the other two days of the
preliminaries I would like to thank
Stephen Pryor uh subramanian John
shirtleffi treats for medo and Jeff
Morrow for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of this wonderful official
random World Championship until it
finishes uh thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day